so it could do something really uh
uplifting and patriotic today for July
4th but we're not really into uplifting
content on this channel so that's how we
really do here so instead we're going to
rebuke rebuke those who have failed in
their own patriotic Duty specifically
while singing the National Anthem now as
I understand it singing the National
Anthem is difficult it's a difficult
song to sing
[Music]
I I can't judge that because every song
is difficult for me to sing because I
have the singing voice of Like A
demented cow
the people who can sing it's it's a
difficult song to nail which is all the
more reason why you just have to be take
it simple sing it as it's supposed to be
song but what we know is that there are
a lot of people get the chance to sing
the national anthem and they want to do
their own thing with it and and
catastrophe is the result so we're gonna
do a top five
I guess the top five of the worst
national anthem performances of all time
and um we'll start with this one you
know this is a singer from the 90s it
gets kind of a bad rap but but but he
deserved it for this performance of the
national anthem at a NASCAR race in
2004. here is uh Scott Stapp of creed
can you
yeah
by the dolls early
what so proudly we hear
is the
twilight's lastly me you know that I
mean he's at a disadvantage because he's
singing acapella to begin with and also
he can't sing so that's the other so
he's really two disadvantages
I'm six feet foreign
not nearly as bad as some of the other
ones on this on this list but it's still
that's like your classic that's sort of
your classic bad national anthem
performance I think it deserves a spot
on the list really it represents many
other bad national anthem performances
we're just picking on Scott Stapp
um which which is unfortunate
[Music]
here's where we get into the really uh
into the nitty-gritty so number four is
Christina Aguilera and I believe the
Super Bowl in 2011 and here's how she
did yeah
I was still there
won't say
does that star spangled bad
way
[Applause]
[Music]
so she's on I think she's on Pitch I
can't really tell as far as I know she
is that's not the issue so before Scott
Stapp Kent saying here she can sing but
she's doing way too much
so she's turned the national anthem into
an opportunity to show off her vocal
range it's not about the flag it's not
about the country it's not about
patriotism it's all about look at me
Christina Aguilera if you want to
perform a song like that you can perform
your own songs like that that's fine but
it's the national anthem it is not
supposed to be a it's it's not written
to be a vocal showcase
and any attempt that you make to turn it
into that it's going to be terrible and
so that's number four on the list
um now we get into the really really bad
stuff next is the band uh The Fray
performing at the final four about 10
years ago and here's their take on the
national anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
you can always tell that's why I think
that's why when you watch the national
these national anthem performances the
performers always have their eyes closed
because they don't want to see the
reaction of the people in the crowd
because you can tell based on the
reaction of the athletes that are
standing on the corridor the field if
they have this like what the hell is
going on kind of expression you know
that you're not you're not doing it the
right way and that was the case here I
mean the national anthem like I don't
know how many times I have to say this
it's not a folk song
I love folk songs that's not what the
national anthem is it can't be that okay
it was not written in most cases if you
just got a folk singer strumming
acoustic guitar and singing some song
about whatever
I will like it I'll be into it but the
acoustic guitar does not belong
on stage during national anthem
performance and it does not belong at a
church those are two places it does not
belong
the national anthem is a certain it is a
certain thing okay are you tired of
waiting ages for your grill to heat up
well now you can say goodbye to those
tedious moments of impatiently watching
the charcoal burn and say hello to
instant barbecue Perfection thanks to
our new friends at Grill Blazer Grill
Blazers Grill guns are designed to do
everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything you can think of that you need
high power fire to solve your problem
girl Blazers offers two types of Grill
guns the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smokers it burns up
to 3 600 Degrees its 30 inch flame is
for anything you need a big bad torch to
do and then the sous vide gun has a
shorter Barrel perfect for professional
Culinary Kitchen uses from gently
caramelizing brulee or other sugars and
fruits to rapidly searing Stakes outside
on the grill using the grill gun may
result in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors and increased demands for
barbecue parties get your grill gun from
Grill Blazers today and let the grilling
Adventures begin visit grillblazer.com
Walsh and use promo code walls for 15
off your order that's grillblazer.com
Wallace promo code wolves for 15 off
your order okay number two we go to
convicted child sex predator R Kelly who
before you went to prison used to be a
big time pop star
um and it was in that capacity that it
was called on years ago I don't know how
long ago this was a while ago to perform
the national anthem before some kind of
big boxing match and we can only assume
that he came up with this Arrangement
after getting punched in the head 15
times himself because otherwise I can't
explain it
let's listen
[Music]
yeah no that's
so the the national anthem is not a folk
song it's also not whatever that
it's not elevator music or r b i don't
know what the hell he was trying to do
there uh that's not what it is listen
here you
for the national anthem remember that it
was written by Francis Scott Key uh uh
as he was as he was remembering uh Fort
McHenry in Baltimore being bombarded
during the war of 1812. you should be
able to imagine that happening you
should be able to imagine people
marching into battle while listening to
the song
if you can't imagine the National Anthem
being performed as troops are Marching
off into battle then it's not a good
performance
[Music]
finally we get uh I mean nothing could
ever top this this performance will live
in infamy this is uh Fergie
at the NBA All-Star Game in 2018
go ahead
[Music]
can you see
by the
drums early
light
what's your problem
s
[Applause]
[Music]
um
I I don't think there have been some
really bad ones that people will
nominate as the worst I mean the
Roseanne performance we didn't even put
up
[Music]
but I I don't think anyone quite any
gets quite as bad as that and that is
that's a national tragedy that is a uh
that's like Pearl Harbor that is Pearl
Harbor in music form
I think we should at least talk about
charges of treason for anyone who
performs the national anthem that poorly
and if I was Theocratic Theocratic
fascist dictator of of uh of the the
country
and you performed like that they're
going to haul you off the court and
throw you in prison that's what needs to
happen
so
don't sing the national anthem like that
today
um but do enjoy yourself now that we've
Afflicted all that on you have a happy
July 4th God Bless America
[Music]